دولة. هل يتجاهل كل تهديدات
روسيا ويقبل جيران موسكو في
الاوان? وليس هذا كل شيء ودول
العالم ستنبش عداوات الماضي. فقد
الولايات المتحدة. وبما ان الحرب
قد اندلعت والعالم مشغول فالصين
حينها. صاروخ يسقط في فرنسا يدمر
باريس معالم الجمال فيها ويحولها
وهناك يقول الروس علينا وعلى
اعدائنا. فهل من رجل رشيد في
الحلف مع معرفة الجميع ان روسيا
لن تقبل اي تهديد وجودي لها.
لكنهما لا تدركان مغبة قرارهما.
الناتو الحلف الذي يجمع ثلاثين
ولكن قبل ذلك لن ينسى نصيب
جيرانه في الجنوبية واليابان.
عواصم دول حلف شمال الاطلسي.
واوضح ان الغرب لن يتوقع ما الذي
هذه هي الحرب العالمية يا سادة.
فهل يدركها الناتو قبل فوات
نرى ايران في حرب ضد اسرائيل وقد
يأخذ العرب بانتقامهم لفلسطين من
ببساطة ولا يجب ان تفعل ذلك لا
بروكسل ولا واشنطن ولا باقي
فان اصبحت هذه الدولتان في حلف
الناتو فذلك يعني وببساطة اندلاع
مرعبة فهناك الصواريخ العابرة
للقارات والشيطان الاكبر صارمات
لاحد توقعها. تمضي فنلندا
والسويد فيما تريانه مصلحة لهما.
يمكن ان يحدث للعالم حينها.
نتائج الحرب العالمية لا يمكن
روسيا ايضا. وسيستغل ذلك بتحقيق
حلمه وسيشارك في ضرب امريكا.
الروسي. لا يجب ان يكون لديهم اي
اوهام عن اننا نغض الطرف عن ذلك
المحتل الاسرائيلي. قالها سيرجي
رياكوف نائب وزير الخارجية
حالة تأهب قتالي. فما بالنا بعد
ان يتوسع الناتو روسيا لابد ان
من ذلك كله اكثر من ستة الاف رأس
نووية. فالى اين ستهرب اوروبا
كبار المسؤولين في دول الناتو
القيادية لانفسهم بالادلاء
يبدأ بوتين هجومه على كل اوروبا
وتمتلك روسيا اسلحة دمار شامل
بتعليقات عدوانية حول بلدنا لذلك
امروا وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
ان تقرر فنلندا والسويد الانضمام
الى الناتو قال بوتين لقد سمح
دقائق. وتستعيد الجزيرة الى
اراضيها. مجنون كوريا لن يترك
مدمرة المصانع وصواريخ تحمل
رؤوسا نووية ستحط في بريطانيا
المدمرة ايضا وسيعم الدمار خراب
روسيا واوروبا وسيصل حتى
الناتو لن يقف مكتوف الايدي.
وهناك ستشترك امريكا باسلحتها
ستقف مع حليفتها روسيا. وفي
الوقت ذاته ستجتاح تايوان في
العامة للقوات المسلحة بوضع قوة
الردع التابعة للجيش الروسي في
اشد اعداء روسيا في اوروبا وتنهي
مظاهر الحياة هناك. لكن بالمقابل
من مدينة الحب الى مدينة الدم
والدمار وقنابل تسقط في المانيا
الذي يرعب العالم. وهناك اسلحة
الشمس الحارقة وما هو اهم واقوى
الحرب التي يخشاها العالم. حرب
شعواء. خلال حرب اوكرانيا، وقبل
الاسلحة والجنود بالقرب من
روسيا؟ ياتي الرد من الكرملين
عمليات روسيا اليهم فان الناتو
سينشر جنوده واسلحته هناك وهو
واكد ان انضمام فنلندا والسويد
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو لن
الامن في اوروبا وسيتغير الوضع
جذريا في اوروبا وربما العالم
انضمام الدولتين للحلف. وبينما
يتوقع ان يستغرق الانضمام اكثر
الانضمام، لكن لانقرة شروط ان
تمت تلبيتها فقد توافق ايضا على
هذه المرة الذي يهدد ان توسع
الناتو بالقرب من روسيا لن يعزز
التهديد الخطير الذي تحذر منه
موسكو دائما فما الذي يعنيه نشر
تركيا وبلسان رئيسها اردوجان
رفضت الامر وحذرت من هذا
فقد يتم الامر بتدخل الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية ويتم قبول
من عام مع المصادقة اللازمة من
قبل الاعضاء الثلاثين في الحلف،
مؤهلتان للانضمام لكسب عضوية
الحلف. هل اقتربت الحرب اكثر؟
العسكري في شمال اوروبا. وبما ان
انضمام الدولتين خوفا من امتداد
يشكل تهديدا في حد ذاته لكن
موسكو سترد على عمليات الانتشار
ردا على قرار السويد وفنلندا ظهر
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بتسريع انضمام السويد وفنلندا
للناتو. واكد البنتاجون ان
الدولتين في الحلف. فماذا لو تم
هذا القرار؟ السيناريو المتوقعة.
القدرات العسكرية للسويد وفنلندا
سترفع من قدرات الغرب في وجه
موسكو الى ما يسعى هؤلاء. الا
يدركون العواقب الوخيمة لهذا
القرار؟ خرج الامين العام لحلف
الناتو يؤكد ان السويد وفنلندا
لكنها اليوم قررت كسر حيادها
والانضمام الى حلف عسكري ولحقت
بها السويد. وهنا خرج الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون وقال انه
الدولتان على الحياد منذ نهاية
الحرب العالمية الثانية وكان
الحلف حتى في دروة الباردة نتيجة
للغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا فقد ضلت
يدعم بشكل تام قرار فنلندا
والسويد بينما تعهدت امريكا
الاوروبيون يضربون المثل بحياد
فنلندا الذي لا تشوبه شائبة
قرار السويد بالانضمام للناتو
وهو ذات القرار الذي وقعت عليه
فنلندا التي تشترك مع روسيا
بحدود طولها الف وثلاثمائة
كيلومتر بانعطافة تاريخية لهذين
البلدين الذين لم ينضما ابدا الى
ليفكر الغرب بضربة موجعة قد تثير
جنون الدب الروسي. وهنا ياتي
والغرب الكثير من فلا العقوبات
نفعت ولا الدعم العسكري حسم.
العسكرية على اوكرانيا بعد ان
اشتدت المعارك وخسرت امريكا
حدودنا فيتسائل الناس في العالم.
ماذا لو انضمت السويد وفنلندا
الى حلف الناتو حقا. اقتراب
الناتو من حدود روسيا ينبئ
مهلا لماذا كل هذا يا هؤلاء. ترد
موسكو الناتو يريد ان يتوسع في
واليابس. العالم واقف يترقب بقلق
ولا يدري كيف سيكون المصير لكن
توسع حلف شمال الاطلسي شرقا صوب
الحدود الروسية من اسباب العملية
طريق الحرب. الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يكرر مرارا ان
باقتراب الحرب العالمية الثالثة
فما الذي سيحدث عندها يا ترى?
التصريحات؟ فنلندا والسويد في
فوهة المدفع. فهل تدركان ذلك قبل
لحظة. ولكنها ليست حربا اوروبية
فقط بل حرب عالمية ستجتاح الاخضر
ويهدد. الاجواء مكهربة في اوروبا
سادة والحرب قد تندلع في اي
وتسهل وتركيا تقول لا. هذا ليس
امرا منطقيا. وبوتين يتوعد
فوات الاوان؟ هكذا يتساءل الروس.
امريكا ترحب وتشجع. اوروبا ترغب
ما هذا الذي يجري؟ ما كل هذه
التوترات؟ ولماذا كل هذه
الناتو يمنع الذي سيحدث للعالم?
العالم يترقب بصمت.